Salut à tous !
Bienvenue dans le Top des Clips honnêtes
C'est le classement des artistes les plus sincères du moment
Numéro 1 cette semaine, le collectif "On Est Là"
Qui chante pour défendre... une cause...
Je ne saurai pas trop vous dire laquelle ...
(Sniff)
En tout cas, ils sont là
Moi je suis là
Pour crier avec toi
Toi que l'on écoute pas
Toi qui vis là-bas, là-bas où il fait si froid
Hein ...
Il fait chaud, autant pour moi
Moi je suis ici par ce que dès qu'il y a une chanson humanitaire
Je me sens obligée de la faire
Moi je suis là pour que les gens ne m'oublient pas
Aaaaaaaaaaaah ...
On est tous là
Pour se battre avec toi
On est tous ici
Pour se sentir investis
Même si on a rien à foutre là
Même si on a rien à foutre ici
Moi je suis là et ça surprend les gens
De voir que je suis toujours vivant
Moi je suis là parce que je suis contre le SIDA
Et c'est ... Et c'est pas là ?
Le studio 14 c'est pas là ?
Ah pardon, je suis désolé, je suis vraiment une tête de linotte des fois, moi !
Moi je suis là parce que je suis marrant
Je fais des grimaces et j'imite des accents
Mais c'est vrai que c'est pas très marrant
Et moi je suis là car je suis animateur télé
Et vu que je ne sais pas chanter
Alors je ne fais que
Parler
On est tous là
Pour se battre avec toi
On est tous ici
Pour se sentir investis
Même si on a rien à foutre là
Même si on a rien à foutre ici
Moi je suis là parce que je suis pianiste
Mais la je fais du play-back
Il faut être réaliste
Vous ne verrez pas de plan
Avec ma bouche et mes mains en même temps
Moi je chante faux
Mais je suis acteur donc c'est pas grave
Moi je suis là parce que c'est ma seule activité
Moi je suis là parce que mon spectacle sort en DVD
Moi je suis là pour déduire ça de mes impôts
C'était pour payer moins en fait
Moi je suis là parce que je suis fan de Michèle Laroque
Il sort aussi en Blu-ray, en VHS, en cassette audio ...
On est tous là
Hé ouais mon gars
Parce que la musique c'est jamais qu'une boucle
Une boucle qui se répète sur 3 ou 4 minutes
Et tous les singles qui se ressemblent
Bah c'est des boucles de boucle
Et moi ça m'émeu vachement
ça m'émeu vachement mais je suis là
On est tous là
Parce que les gens c'est ce qu'ils veulent mon gars
Ils veulent des trucs qu'ils connaissent
ça les rassure mon gars
On est tous là
Pour se battre avec toi
On est tous ici
Pour se sentir investis
Même si on a rien à foutre là
Même si on a rien à foutre ici
On est tous là